SUNIL RAYAN: My
name is Sunil Rayan.
I lead Google Cloud for
Games team here at Google.
And it's an honor for
me to be here today.
As you can imagine
and see, Google
has announced some really
big things this week.
So I'm sure many of you attended
Mobile Developer Day on Monday.
And if you haven't,
you should definitely
check out the Tuesday keynote.
We announced a big
platform called Stadia.
And today, for the
first time, we actually
have an entire day dedicated
to Google Cloud developers.
And we've got a fantastic
lineup of speakers,
both subject matter
experts from Google
but more importantly,
customers and partners
that are going to talk about how
Google Cloud is helping power
their games.
But before we get
into this, I want
to take a step back and talk
a little bit about the trends
that we're seeing and how it
affects our approach in Google
Cloud.
You all know there has been an
amazing explosion of players
globally-- about
2 billion, which
means there's huge opportunity.
And the industry is growing
at a tremendous rate.
And this is all thanks
to people like you
who, with your creativity,
are building fantastic games.
So that's one.
So we're dealing
with massive scale.
Second, it's just not
about players, right?
The business of games took about
35 years to get to $35 billion
in revenue.
But then in the
subsequent 11 years,
we've added another
$100 billion annually.
So it's not just there
are lots of players.
There's a lot of
money in this market.
And it's kind of becoming
the biggest entertainment
industry out there.
So that's number two.
Because we are seeing ways
for people to monetize.
Number three, what
we are also seeing
is with the
democratization of devices,
you have to reach
a player base that
is of different sizes and shapes
and different screen sizes.
And what people
are starting to see
is with 5G coming and low
latency in different areas,
AAA games or mobile games
are thinking that people are
going to be platform agnostic.
So you need to start building
for different sizes and shapes
and some of these things
that we talked about even
in yesterday's keynote
on Stadia, that you can
play across different devices.
Lastly, as a trend
that we're also seeing
is a game is just
not a game anymore.
It's becoming an ecosystem.
You have successful games that
have more developers creating
content.
We have social
connections, and things
can explode from day one.
So it's really hard to
forecast what's going
to happen and prepare for it.
And the second thing is, as
a result, games' lifetime
is becoming longer
and longer because you
have ways to update content.
So the new normal,
pretty much, right
now is to you need to
constantly develop and iterate.
And that's the new normal
for building games.
So these are the trends that
we took into account and said,
OK, how does that affect
what the Google Cloud game
strategy should be and how
we can help developers?
And after talking
to a lot of you,
we also heard there
are four things
that we need, taking
the trends into account
and what we heard from you.
One, you want scale from day one
if you want to be successful.
You don't want any obstacles
when you launch a game to say,
oops, I couldn't scale, so I'm
not going to be successful.
So that's one.
Number two, with all
the different devices
and with the
different platforms,
you want flexibility so you
can build once and deploy it
in as many places as you want.
Number three, you also said, I
want less operational overhead,
and I just want to focus
on building good games.
And lastly, given
you never know what
you can expect in
terms of players,
you want better ability
to predict outcomes.
You want better ability
to forecast where players
are coming from, et cetera.
So predictability is
becoming a core need
for a lot of game
developers, as well.
So we took this into
account and said,
what does Google Cloud for
Games actually stand for?
So one-- you will hear a lot
about this from us throughout
the rest of day--
one, we want to enable
cross-platform services
and solutions.
Number two, we are
committed to open source.
You will see in
subsequent sessions
that we'll talk
a little bit more
about how we are partnering
with the industry
to push the thought
leadership forward.
And we want to give
developers choice.
Number three, Google has been
used to having lots of data
and building analytics,
predictive algorithms.
Machine learning
is becoming core.
So you will see a lot of machine
learning services from Google.
And lastly, if you haven't
seen the commitment,
I would say for the
first time we have--
the number of Googlers
at GDC is exploding.
And that's because we have
a commitment for games.
And what that
results in is we want
to bring the best of Google to
you across different product
areas and different solutions.
And you will hear some of
that later today, as well.
Let me dive a little
bit into it to say
this is not just in theory.
We actually have top AAA
games and mobile games
running on Google Cloud.
This is just a sample
list of game titles,
as well as partners
that we're working with,
like Multiplay and
Unity and Improbable,
that's helping advance what
Cloud can do for your games.
So diving a little bit
deeper into our strategy,
one of the things that
we have committed to
is giving developers choice.
In a lot of things
in Google Cloud,
we have this platform
called Kubernetes,
which is based on containers.
And we feel like that's
something that gives choice
because you can run Kubernetes
on Google Cloud, on-premise,
on your bare metal, as
well as on other clouds.
And we're just not committed
to this in Google Cloud.
We're committed to that
in gaming in Google Cloud,
as well.
And some of the examples
that we have partnered
with the industry to push
that thinking on is, one,
we've got a open-source
project called Agones
that we launched
about a year ago
that you'll hear more of which
automatically helps you scale
your game server processes.
So you don't have
to worry about it.
And it also gives
you a good dashboard
of metrics on how servers
are scaling up and down.
We've also-- again, with an
industry partner, with Unity--
launched Open Match, which
is a matchmaking service.
It's open source.
Anybody could take and use it
and put in your specific logic
in to make matchmaking work.
So we're just not
saying open source.
We are actually doing
specific projects
that are related to games.
It's also not just that we
are funding these projects.
We are also making it
easy for you to access it.
And as of today, you can use
Agones with a simple click
from the Cloud Marketplace
and embed it into your game.
So this is something that
is very exciting for us
and helps advance Kubernetes and
game servers into the industry,
as well.
The next part in
our strategy is we
want you to get results fast
and get more player insights.
Because you want to improve
the player experience,
as well as get more
insight from your players.
And we've partnered
with lots of-- sorry,
I flipped the slide.
Can you go back one?
We've also partnered
with a lot of companies--
big companies which have
humongous amounts of data,
like 50 petabytes--
with people like
King and Square Enix,
to bring more insights
about your players so
you can improve the
design of your game
or improve the
monetization of your game.
On infrastructure, we also
partnered very closely with
Massive Entertainment studios--
can you go to the next slide,
please?--
to help launch "Tom
Clancy Division 2."
And we have a model where
we our custom engineers
were in the war room to
make sure this launch was
successful.
This actually launched
on Friday last week.
So this is a little bit
of what we talked about.
And lastly, I'll
finish on our strategy.
We want to bring
the best of Google.
We want to help the
game industry succeed.
We want to help
developers succeed.
And we feel Google Cloud is
the glue to those efforts.
And with that, we want to work
with different Google teams
to bring this to life.
And on that note, I'm sure you
heard about Stadia yesterday.
And let me bring up
our next speakers, who
are going to discuss how Stadia
and GCP, and Google Cloud
Platform, are actually
better together.
Micah?
[APPLAUSE]
MICAH BAKER: Thank you, Sunil.
Good morning.
I'm Micah Baker.
I'm a product manager for
gaming on Google Cloud.
And I'm joined by my
colleague, Pawel, who
is a product manager on Stadia.
And I'm sure you would love
to hear a little bit more
about that exciting
announcement from yesterday.
And so I'm going to
hand it over to Pawel
to talk a little
bit about Stadia.
And then, I'll talk about how
Google Cloud and Stadia work
better together.
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ: Thank you.
So Stadia was
announced yesterday.
Who's seen the keynote or has
heard a little bit about it?
OK.
Fair number.
So as a quick summary, Stadia
is a new kind of platform.
It's a cloud-based gaming
platform for AAA gaming
that is based on streaming.
And it is a new
platform that lets
you build new kinds of games.
But we have built it to
be intuitive and work
with all kinds of games.
And so we're very excited
about what we can bring to it.
And what makes it
unique, of course,
is that because it is hosted
in Cloud and it streams,
it can connect to different
devices and different endpoints
without having to change
the core game experience
or how you build it.
We're launching in 2019.
And the reason this is
relevant to this audience,
specifically, for
the Google Cloud
is that whenever your
game is running on Stadia,
it's always running in a
virtualized environment
on a specialized VM that
we call an instance.
And these instances connect to
the endpoints through a stream,
through the internet
and Wi-Fi and whatever
the player is playing on.
But the part that is
important to remember for here
is that the Stadia
instances aren't generic GCP
virtual machines.
They are specialized.
And so you will interact with
them in the Stadia environment.
Now, when players
are playing, we
take care of those instances.
So once you launch your game,
when players are playing,
we manage all of that, so you
don't have to worry about it.
But when you're in development
and you have your developer
instances, then you will
be interacting with them
in our environment.
And this is where some
of the power of the GCP
can come in because all of
the Stadia infrastructure
is running on the same
backbone that GCP is running.
And so the connection to GCP
is very fast and efficient.
And to talk a little
bit more about that,
I'll pass it on to Micah.
MICAH BAKER: Thank you.
So now that you understand a
little bit of the logistics
of Stadia, it's interesting
to compare how that fits in
with the Google Cloud story.
Google Cloud has a unique
global private network,
which is really fundamental
in this better value
that we're going
to talk about here.
So you think about all
these different connections
across the globe.
And having a private
network really matters
when you want to
control latency.
What does this do to
Stadia, for example?
So when you work with
Google Cloud and Stadia,
that private network
actually comes in very handy
because we can have
all the traffic local.
The traffic never has to
go through the internet,
as you may experience
through other clouds.
What happens if your network
traffic gets to stay local,
though?
What does that bring to your
game and to your experience?
It really comes down to
these three main points.
Your traffic is never
exposed to the internet,
so no one can mess
with your traffic.
The game data is
going to be secure.
You can count on
the performance.
It's predictably low
latency because it's always
on that private
network where we can
control the quality of service.
It's also a great
value because there's
no charge for egressing to
the internet from the cloud.
So we're really excited
about the combination
of Stadia and Google Cloud.
And we look forward to
talking more about this.
This was just a little sneak
peek into what we're thinking.
And next, I'm going to
hand it over to Pawel
to talk a little bit
about what you can
do to learn more about Stadia.
PAWEL SIARKIEWICZ: Thank you.
So just to finish
off this, if you
would like to work
with Stadia, if you
have a game idea that you'd
like to bring to our platform,
then please head
over to stadia.dev,
and we'd love to hear from you.
And we're taking these
[? developer ?] applications
now.
And then, we'll be
getting back to you
throughout the rest of the year.
And also, come see us
at our booths and demos.
If you actually
want to check out
some of the tools,
how they work,
we're in the West Hall
for the developer section.
And the South Hall has more
of the playability sections.
And so you can
both experience it
and see what it will look like
to actually build on Stadia.
Thank you.
MICAH BAKER: All right.
So we're very excited to
continue this conversation
offline if you have
any more questions.
And next, I'd like to invite my
friend Paul up from Multiplay,
where we're going to talk
a little bit about some
of our successes
and working together
on scaling their games.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL MANUEL: Thank you.
Thank you, Micah.
Good morning, everyone.
My name's Paul Manuel.
I'm the managing
director of Multiplay.
Thank you to Google for asking
us to come and talk today.
What I'm going to be
touching on is, essentially,
what Multiplay do to give
you a little bit of context,
why we work so
closely with Google,
and I'm going to talk about
quite an exciting case study,
which we worked on this year.
Click.
OK.
Just to frame it
up a little bit,
I think it's worth explaining
a little bit about Multiplay
and what we do.
So we are game server
hosting specialists.
And believe it or
not, we've been doing
this for nearly 20 years now.
So we have launched
a lot of games.
And I wouldn't say we've seen
it all, but we've seen a lot.
Now, we don't create games,
but we do power them.
So effectively,
that is our calling.
So a lot of you in the
audience create games.
But our thing is we power
them through infrastructure.
And it is our belief that
we have a responsibility
to the game players of
the world when they invest
either their money or their
valuable time to get on a game
and be able to play it
quickly, fast, lag-free.
And likewise, we also feel
like we have an obligation
to the game developers.
Whether you're a studio with
two people or 200 people,
if you're going to invest two
or three years of your life
into building the
most awesome game,
then when it comes
to launch day,
you've got to make
sure you get it right
and all those customers
get to play your game.
And that's our job.
So we work hard on this.
And we've been working with
Google Cloud for probably
getting on near four years now.
And I'll talk a little
bit more about that.
Just to finish that story
and finish the framing,
at the tail end
of 2017, Multiplay
became part of the Unity family.
So we're super
proud to join Unity.
And if you know
anything about Unity,
you know that they're the world
leading real-time creation
platform.
And they build awesome
tools for creating games.
But what you may not know is
beyond the creation phase,
as Unity, we now move into
the operational phase.
And this is where
Multiplay sits.
So we provide the infrastructure
for large online multiplayer
games.
You'll hear soon more about
the Multiplay matchmaker.
And we also have Vivox, who
are similar to Multiplay--
they've joined the
Unity family recently--
who power voice comms
for some of the largest
games in the world, including
"Fortnite" and "PUBG"
and so on.
So the operational
phase is something
that we do a great deal of.
The important
message here, though,
is we are engine agnostic.
So at Multiplay,
we will host games
regardless of what engine it
is, whether it's Unreal, Unity,
or whatever, we work on those.
So on to cloud.
Let's talk about
cloud and the impact
it has on the gaming industry.
Well, it is true that cloud is
a game changer, that's for sure.
You can now do
stuff that you never
used to be able to do before.
In the past, before
cloud existed,
when you came to launch your
game, one of two scenarios
would exist.
You either had too much hardware
and only this many players
turned up-- and that's an
expensive situation to be in--
or, arguably even worse, you
have this much hardware--
not enough--
and this many players
turn up, in which case--
and we've all been there.
That's when you can't get into
the game, the most frustrating
situation to be in.
And it was a very, very
difficult problem to solve.
And if you had that
second scenario,
then you'd find
yourself scrambling,
trying to get more servers
in, whereas cloud actually
enables us to get rid of
that problem completely.
I'm just going to talk
about three very typical--
we've seen many, many
shapes of launches,
but here's a few examples.
This is the one we call the
highly anticipated launch, OK?
So this is the game
that everybody knows.
Everybody knows it's coming.
And maybe it's a first-person
shooter that comes out just
before Christmas every year,
or it's a seasonal sports title
or something like that.
So you know it's coming.
Or maybe it's a massively
hyped new IP that everybody's
super excited to hear about.
And along comes
launch day, and that's
what the peak looks like.
And it looks like this
pretty much every time.
And that peak is massive.
And it lasts for a week or
two, or maybe a month or so,
and then it dies down.
And then, hopefully,
what happens
is people stay engaged in
the game, the people who
love the game.
And then, you invest in it,
and it grows from there.
So that's the
anticipated launch.
Next slide.
We also see quite a bit of this.
And we have games that we host
at Multiplay exactly like this.
So this is your games
as a service type model.
They're seasonal.
They will have large DLCs
or large events going on,
large promotions,
large tournaments,
or they have seasons, and
you'll see three or four spikes
like this per year.
The message to take away,
again, it's a different shape,
but what's consistent is it's
very, very erratic and very
spiky.
And you have to have
enough infrastructure
to cope with each one of those
spikes accurately every time.
And the third example
I'll give you--
and, possibly, for me, the
most exciting one of all--
is the game that nobody knew
was going to come along,
and it was a massive hit.
So this is the unexpected hit.
And we've seen this with "PUBG."
We've seen this with "Fortnite,"
and we've seen it with
the likes of "Pokémon GO" and,
more recently, "Apex Legends."
And I'll talk a little bit
more about "Apex" in a minute.
But what I can tell you
is an extreme version
of that very graph
happened with "Apex
Legends" in the first
week of its launch.
And this is the tough one.
Because this is the
one when you literally
have no idea how many
players are going to turn up.
But if a lot turn
up-- in the millions--
then you need to be
absolutely sure you
have the Cloud and
the infrastructure
and the orchestration layer
ready to scale it to that.
OK.
So onto a little bit
of case study for you.
As I said, we work with
many, many different games.
We work with "Rocket League."
We work with "PUBG."
We work with Tripwire
on "Killing Floor."
But we have a very special
relationship with our friends
at Respawn.
And going back a
couple of years,
we did the launch
for "Titanfall 2."
And collectively, this is where
we really honed our craft,
I think, in terms of blending
multiple clouds and bare metal
infrastructure into
one single fabric,
enabling their matchmaker just
to talk to us via a single API.
So they have a game.
They say we have a
group of players.
We're ready to go.
We need a server on US West.
Multiplay, can I have it?
Boom.
And we come back
with the server.
What happens behind the scenes
they don't need to know about.
It's magic to them.
But as you can
imagine, it's a blend
of multiple clouds
and bare metal.
But there's a lot of
GCP in there, as well.
So "Titanfall 2" was
a phenomenal launch.
It was flawless.
All the players got to play.
The game had incredible reviews,
super, super high Metacritic
rating.
But the only shame, I
guess, in some respects,
is not quite as many
players turned up
as everybody had hoped for.
However, fast forward
a couple years.
And Respawn, once again,
in February of this year,
we launched "Apex."
The key difference
here, of course,
is this game was free to play.
And what actually happened
is in the first eight hours,
we saw a million players.
And then, in the first
72 hours, or three days,
we saw 10 million
players that we served.
And within the
first four weeks, we
have saw 50 million players on
this game, each one of them,
on the whole, always getting in
and having a great experience
in "Apex Legends."
And how do we prep for
something like that?
Well, if you can see that
little video running,
it's all about
preparation, actually.
It's about testing.
This stuff doesn't
happen by magic.
This is us scaling up GCP
in advance, as a test,
to an enormous number we
picked out of thin air--
14 million players.
And if you watch the
top right-hand corner,
you will see that we spun up,
in a period of 90 minutes,
enough capacity to serve 14
million concurrent players
in a game.
We weren't expecting
that amount of numbers,
but we tested it
in advance, anyway.
And what we were
testing here is not
just GCP's ability to scale at
the pace that we needed it to.
We were testing our
own core infrastructure
to ensure that it could
take that volume of requests
in that amount of
time, which it did.
But the real key message
to take away from here
is test in advance, OK?
So as amazing as
Google Cloud is,
or any cloud, and as amazing
as our own orchestration
layer is that I
love to talk about,
you still have a matchmaker.
It still needs to
work in the right way.
It needs to be stress tested.
One of the great
things about working
with a studio such as
Respawn, if you've ever
played any of their
games, you will
see that they are meticulous
in everything they do.
And I can tell you from
firsthand experience,
they are meticulous at
their testing, as well.
So test in advance.
Make sure you're ready.
Work with a partner, so
when it comes to that day,
having worked for all those
years of building your game,
you are ready for
launch, and things work,
and players get in.
And that can make
or break a game.
And I can tell you when it
goes wrong, Twitter lights up.
Because I follow the
term server on Twitter.
And I know what it
looks like when things
go wrong and Twitter lights up.
And it will be in the
thousands of people.
Well, I can tell you in the
launch of "Apex Legends,"
Twitter was very quiet.
In fact, what was
wonderful about
it is we saw a whole
bunch of tweets
about people saying, wow.
Has this game just launched
to this many players
with no server problems?
And that was a lovely,
lovely thing to see.
So with "Apex Legends,"
we went from zero
to hitting over two
million concurrent players
in the first seven days.
We spun up in GCP 6,500 VMs.
And these are big
VMs, by the way.
These are meaty machines.
And that was across
53 locations globally.
And the vast majority of the
game was in Google Cloud.
So why do we work so
closely with Google?
Well, actually, there's
a number of reasons.
And I've called out four here.
Winding back to when we
first looked at cloud,
we benchmark, and we still, to
this day, use multiple clouds.
But we benchmarked
Google, and one
of the things that our
engineers loved was,
actually, it was
very simple to use.
In fact, in their
words, they found
that they thought they had the
gold standard of documentation.
And what it meant is we had
no experience in Google Cloud,
and within a very
short space of time,
we were up and running with
very little help from them
in the sense that their
documentation was excellent.
The other thing is
scale, of course.
Google are continuing
to invest not
only in their phenomenal
network but in terms
of the amount of data centers
they have around the world.
And they continue
that investment today.
So we get global coverage.
Performance was the
big one, though.
What we really,
really cared about is
from making a
request to a server,
how quickly can we
get that server back?
You can imagine when
you're scaling from zero
to two million
concurrents, you need
to be sure that you're
getting virtuals
back very, very quickly.
With "Apex Legends," we
will get a server back
from a cold request
to up, run, and booted
in less than two minutes.
And then we do a little bit of
Multiplay magic on top of that,
and then the server is in
the pool, ready to be used.
To be super clear there, no
player waits for two minutes.
So our algorithms at
Multiplay is constantly
tracking the rate of change to
ensure that we have servers up
and running and
warm, ready to go, as
soon as the request comes in.
So players were
in in an instant.
But yeah, incredible
performance.
And then, the last
one, which you rarely
hear people talk about
when they talk about cloud
is the people, actually.
So we've had a phenomenal
partnership with Google
from day one.
And even when Multiplay
was a lot smaller
than what it is
today, they really
looked after us in terms
of testing stuff, doing
unusual stuff, making
sure everything worked.
And then, the launch
of "Apex Legends,"
again, we were able to scale
to phenomenal amounts of VMs
in a short amount of time.
And that's because we
had Google Cloud working
very, very closely with us to
make sure we were well-prepared
for this project.
So the partnership, in terms of
the people, is absolutely key.
So final wrap-up for me, really,
is, I guess, for you guys--
you know this-- making games
is a very, very difficult thing
to do.
So it would be great if
you just had one less
thing to worry about.
And for me, I think
it's the infrastructure.
So if there's one thing you
take away from this talk today,
is that we know that
creativity is the beating
heart of any game studio.
But you don't need to worry
about the infrastructure
logistics.
Those problems have
been solved by companies
like us many, many, many,
many times over, OK?
And here's a quote from
John Shiring from Respawn.
He says, "For the launch of
'Apex Legends,' it was critical
both that we could scale our
servers up to handle whatever
size audience showed up and that
those servers were reliable.
We continued our
partnership with Multiplay
to leverage their
multi-cloud auto-scaler
so we can focus our developer
time on the game itself
and not on keeping the
game servers running."
That's absolutely key.
John Shiring, not
just from Respawn
but from "Call of
Duty," "Infinity Ward
Call of Duty," "Modern
Warfare," and all those games.
These are very
experienced people,
and they've made the
decision, actually,
let's let someone else look
after the infrastructure.
We'll concentrate on the game.
That's it for me.
Thank you very much.
I'm going to hand back to Micah.
[APPLAUSE]
MICAH BAKER: Thank you, Paul.
One of my favorite things
about Multiplay is the people.
Technology is great,
but people are what
make the relationships work.
And Multiplay excels
at relationships,
so we're really pleased
to work with them.
I also wanted to
mention that one
of the benefits of using, for
example, Multiplay or hosting
games on GCP, in general,
along with Stadia,
is that you're in a perfect
position to be cross-platform.
So you'll be able to host
your game servers in one place
and service all the
different screens that you
want to get your game to.
So it's my pleasure to
invite our next speaker up,
Rami Ismail, who will be talking
to us about our developers
and global diversity.
[APPLAUSE]
RAMI ISMAIL: Hi.
As a game developer,
you quickly come
to realize that play
is a global language.
It is something that
people understand,
regardless of their
culture, their language,
or their heritage.
If you put a ball on the ground,
no matter where in the world
you are and you kick
it towards somebody,
you'll find that
they kick it back.
Over the past decade or so,
I've traveled around the world
to meet and assist
game developers that
work in the widest possible
variety of circumstances,
from developers that work
in the ice-cold north
and a month-long
night to developers
that are making games
on a cliff overlooking
the plains of Africa.
And during those
travels, I've always
aimed to assist developers
with the challenges
unique to their country, access
to knowledge, to experience,
to press, funding,
and to technology.
And it has been my career
goal to democratize access
to our technology, to our
libraries of knowledge,
and to our industry.
To further that goal, a group of
talented games industry members
and myself have
founded gamedev.world,
which is an online,
livestreamed, multilingual
games conference.
And as we gather here
in San Francisco,
it is worth considering the
privilege and opportunity
that events like the Game
Developers Conference
offer creators that are Western
or that speak English or that
have economical access
to these events.
So from June 21 until June 23,
gamedev.world will livestream
for free game developer talks
in eight major languages
of the world--
English, French, Spanish,
Brazilian Portuguese, Japanese,
simplified Chinese,
Russian, and Arabic.
Speakers from all
over the world,
speaking in their
native tongues,
will share their knowledge,
perspectives, and stories.
And for the first time in the
history of the games industry,
we'll be able to share that
knowledge across the language
barrier through live subtitling.
The internet was touted as a
globally connective technology,
a technology that would allow
us to reach beyond our cities,
to speak across our borders, and
to create for global audiences.
It has achieved
many of those goals,
but many challenges and
opportunities remain.
So as we advance
through 2019, it
is critical to acknowledge
that major technologies don't
support non-Latin languages
in their software or websites,
that global often means
everywhere but Africa,
and that inclusivity is often
a shortcut for inclusivity
for those who speak English.
It is important to realize that
through technology, diversity,
and proactive efforts, we
can challenge and defeat
many of those notions
if only we consider
that the internet is larger
than the Latin alphabet,
that access to
high-speed internet
is still not ubiquitous, and
that language and access are
some of the largest invisible
privileges all of us
in this room share.
We've seen the internet
connect players
all over the world to
play games together,
despite not sharing a language.
We've seen how global
communities solve problems
together, create beautiful
content in games together,
and play together,
despite never meeting.
The games industry
has pioneered ways
of play, ways of
connectivity, that
are unrestrained by language
and universal in their reach.
So as I travel the world to meet
the game development community
in emerging territories--
sometimes half a dozen
creators, sometimes
hundreds of them--
I see how open-source
technology and free tool sets
have democratized our industry.
I see how knowledge sharing
takes a little bit of time
but affects thousands of careers
and lives across the world.
I see how community
translation makes
information available in one
language available in another.
And I've seen how making
issues of access and issues
of opportunity more visible
through the internet
has enabled our
industry to respond
to challenges we would otherwise
be entirely unaware of.
At gamedev.world, we
think about those truths
as we prepare for the event.
We're optimists
about the potential
of technology in the world.
We are optimists about
the role of the internet
as connective tissue
between humans.
We are optimists
about equalizing
opportunity and access
through the networks that
already exist.
And we believe that progress
is both to dream about what
isn't possible yet
and to critically
examine what is available
to only a few of us.
We have found the same values
and that same enthusiasm
and optimism in the
Google Cloud team.
We are extremely grateful
for their support
as a diamond sponsor
for gamedev.world.
Our goal is to, even
if just for one moment,
shatter the language
barrier and show
the medium and industry
of games as it truly
is-- a global force, a universal
language not constrained
by the language we speak,
the place we are born,
or the access we have.
As the gamedev.world team
works to present the first ever
international games
conference, we
hope that you will sign up for
the conference at gamedev.world
and that you will join us live
on the internet on June 21.
Thanks so much.